manifestation cet après midi à roissy
pour défendre l'emploi aérien
particulièrement touché par la crise
sanitaire nombre de participants 2000
selon les syndicats 900 d'après la
police l'appel de quatre organisations
toutes les branches du transport aérien
à l'exception du personnel navigant se
sont mobilisés devant l'aéroport charles
de gaulle zéro licenciement c'est ce que
réclament les salariés alors qu'air
france par exemple souhaite supprimer
7000 581 postes d'ici la fin de l'année
les manifestants demandent également la
mise en place de mesures de soutien
supplémentaires dans la filière ont
donné sept milliards hier france et ya
zéro dans le package à 0 pour la
sous-traitance
aujourd'hui il ya des milliers de
licenciements aujourd'hui qui sont sur
la table
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
alors on ne joue pas il ya pas moins de
800 salariés qui se sont fait licencier
pour l'instant et mais c'est qu'un début
au jour d'aujourd'hui on se retrouve en
liquidation judiciaire et redressement
judiciaire ij et 435 salariés qui
peuvent être à la porte
le moins ans d'âge c'est 47 ans le
plupart on a 25 ans à 30 ans
d'ancienneté sur la plate forme et on
demande à air france pourquoi au jour
d'aujourd'hui on arrive à ce point-là
saute sur l'occasion
du coup vide pour voilà pour pour
décliner le maximum de salariés a tout
simplement